I find extremely uncommon to an awkward
as a man Depp to stand on your tiptoes
to kiss a girl my knee-jerk response
that is hard-headed I think that a lot
of those who would understand that term
or use that term or use that as part of
their philosophy
we're probably hard-headed kids that had
a real problem at times listening to
their parents but my mother my nickname
was hard hat you know she would call me
that and shortstack
I think that I'm pretty the hell bent on
working hard and keeping a tight
schedule and punctuality and trying to
listen to everybody around me and make
good decisions Rupert Murdoch is
definitely a maverick I mean he's a guy
that runs Fox American I also have a say
on that network and I think that he's
subscribed to that psychology and
clearly been very successful and it
seems appropriate that with American
Idol on the air maybe he'll see this and
if not his assistant much that kind of
thing
I like any Italian cooking shows massive
Giada fan I had a crush
until she because she's in love with her
husband and so and I she came in and I
interviewed her and she's really in love
with him so kind of like he crushes you
but I do like everything that she makes
him there's something about those shows
that they're escapism their liking and
Regis Dick Clark and my friend who is no
longer with us Merv Griffin they just
they loved it and it was second nature
to them and so those are the guys that I
think I think did it they did it for a
long time they loved it they were happy
they achieved what they wanted to
achieve and they built businesses to
I wouldn't sing I'd wrap it's because I
was born with rhythm in the rhyme you
know I grew up a Run DMC Beastie Boys
young MC fan I can put my shoulder to my
headphone and mix it up on the ones and
twos feet to beating back to back